so what's a quadratic factor it's when
you have an x squared factor an x
squared group here okay so what we want
to do is we want to break this down into
its original fractions before we
combined it into this fraction here so
we're decomposing it breaking it down
and so what we're going to do is this is
already factored for us the denominator
if it wasn't factored you'd want to
factor it first okay but I've already
factored it here for us so what we have
is ax squared plus 2 plus X plus 3 now
because this is a second-degree we want
the numerator to be one degree lower so
I'm going to write this as ax plus BC X
to the first this is x squared this is
one degree lower and we go in descending
order now if this was a cubic term then
we would want ax squared plus BX plus C
so it would go one degree lower and go
in descending order till you get to the
constant this one's a linear factor X
plus three X to the first so I'm just
going to make this a constant see you
don't want to reuse any of the variables
so that's why I keep going ABCDE like
that so now what we're gonna do is we're
going to clear the denominators by
multiplying by the common denominator
this is the common denominator here and
so what I'm going to do is I'm gonna
multiply the left and right sides the
entire equation by x squared plus 2x
plus 3 if we do that that's going to
clear this denominator just leave us
with 5 x squared plus 10 X plus 7 equals
ax plus B times X plus 3 plus C times x
squared plus 2 okay so now we've got it
okay we've cleared the denominators now
what I'm going to show you in this
particular video is a little bit
different than I showed you in some of
the other videos what I'm going to do is
I'm just going to foil out this right
side here and we're going to get a
system of equations we're going to solve
that system so first let's foil this
together we're going to get ax squared
plus 3 ax plus BX plus 3b plus
distribute the C here we get C x squared
plus 2c now what I want to do is I want
to group together
the x squared terms so we have ax
squared plus CX squared I'm going to
group the X terms together so we have
three ax
okay plus BX okay and I'm going to group
the constant terms together now which
those are just going to be three B and 2
C so that's three B plus two C okay and
that equals five x squared plus 10 X
plus 7 now what I'm going to do here is
I'm going to factor out the x squared so
that's going to be a plus C times x
squared here I'm going to factor out the
X so that's going to leave us with 3 a
plus B times X if you distribute the X
back in and get back the original here
and here I'm just going to leave this as
3 B plus 2 C okay now what we're going
to do is we're going to set C this is x
squared right C this is x squared we're
going to set a plus C equal to 5 okay so
a plus C equals 5 we're going to set 10
C 10 X here is X we're gonna set this
coefficient equal to this coefficient so
we have 3 a plus B equals 10 and then
the constant 7 we're going to set equal
to this constant on the right side 3 B
plus 2 C so we have 3 B plus 2 C equals
7 so now you can see what we have here
is we have a system of equations we're
going to solve this system and we're
going to find our a B and C so let's
take a look at this system so what
should we try to eliminate here well
let's see we've got a a okay we've got B
and B we've got C and C okay so what
should we do to eliminate this why don't
we multiply this first equation times
negative 3 okay so if we do that we get
negative 3a minus 3 C equals negative 15
I'm going to add it to this equation
here three a plus B equals ten if we add
those together you can see the A's are
going to cancel and we get B minus three
C equals negative five okay so far so
good so now we're going to combine these
two equations together they just have
B's and C's okay to solve for either B
or C so why don't we multiply this
equation here times negative 3 and
combine it with this equation so if we
do that multiplied by negative 3 we're
going to get negative 3 v + 9 C equals
15 so if we combine these together we
get 11 C equals 22 so now we know C
equals 2 if we take the 2 and we work
our way back let's put 2 in here we get
well we could put into any one of the
equations really if we don't see us -
let's put it into this equation that
means a must be 3 ok so now you know a
equals 3 we just have to solve for B
okay if we know that a is 3 that's going
to be 3 times 3 is 9 which means that B
must be 1 okay so B equals 1 and now we
have our a B and C we can put those back
in for a B and C here and these are
going to be our partial fractions you
can check your work if you get a common
denominator or combine these into one
fraction you can verify that you get
back this original fraction so this has
been how to do partial fraction
decomposition when you have a quadratic
meaning a second-degree factor I'll see
you in the next video